The init method you wrote for
RPS turn and
RPS game probably looked
something like this.
Let's walk through the method
definition syntax one more time.
The dash tells us that this
is an instance method.
Then in parentheses here,
we have the type of the method returns,
which in this case, matches the type of
the class to which the method belongs.
After the return type becomes
the method name, followed by a colon,
then we have the parameter type in
between parentheses followed by
the parameter name, and then the body
of the method in between curly braces.
What about when we're passing
in more than one parameter?
Like in the RPSGames init method?
When you're passing in
more than one parameter,
the parameters get interspersed
with the method name.
So in the RPS came example,
the method name is here and
here, and the general form
would look something like this.
Also notice that when we pass in
an RPS turn object as a parameter.
We need an asterisk to indicate
the pointer to the object but
when we pass in a move
which is an integer.
We don't need a pointer.